Hello world.
Welcome to throw geology.
Ever wonder how Netflix recommends often
shows you like or how Facebook can auto
tag your face or how Google's self
driving cars work or how big can,
what's that? You don't care
what [inaudible] does, it's
okay. Nobody does. Anyways,
the answer is machine learning.
Machine learning is a study of
algorithms that learn from examples and
experience instead of hard coded rules.
So let's say you want to build an app
that can recognize an image of a specific
species of flower called Iris.
If you decide to code this
without machine learning,
you'd have to write a bunch of different
functions to detect all the different
features of an iris flower.
The problem is there are a bunch of
corner cases and there's no way you can
account for all of them ahead of time.
Like what if one of the leads is partially
obstructed or a flower is a certain
color that you didn't account for or
the shape is totally different than what
you expected. You can't just code all that
up beforehand unless you're Jeff Dean.
Just kidding. Jeff Dean
can't do it. Nobody can.
You have to use machine learning to solve
this problem and here's the best part.
It's actually super easy and you don't
need to be a math person to do it.
They're just four steps involved in the
process. Collect data, pick the model,
train the model and test the model.
We'll basically just add data to a model
and it will start to find patterns in
the data for us. We're going to make
this Irish flower recognition APP,
which has seven lines of python
using two dope libraries,
psychic learn and tensorflow which
will important right at the start.
So let's do this. The first step is
to get our data. Data sets come in,
all different kinds of formats, pdf, CSVs,
holograms. It doesn't matter the format.
We can easily parse it in our
code to get the relevant details.
We'll be using a well known data set that
contains 150 samples of Iris Flowers.
Luckily for us, this data set
comes preloaded with psychic learn,
so we can just load it here. Each sample
has a label, one of three types of Iris,
toasted, Virginica or versicolor.
And instead of features,
Sepa Lang Sipa with pedaling and pedal
with, because our data is labeled,
the type of learning we're doing
is called supervised learning.
If we didn't have labels for our data,
just features,
they don't want to be called
unsupervised learning. So yeah,
these are good features there.
Simple,
independent and informative as all
features should be. By the way,
if you're ever deciding on what kind
of features you should look for in a
Dataset,
a good rule of thumb is thinking about
what features you personally would need
to figure out to determine
whatever your goal is.
So if you're trying to determine Jedi
or sith given a data set of lightsabers,
don't pick something like
weapons status as a feature.
Use Blade colors and curvature as your
feature. So now that we have our Dataset,
the next step is to pick the model.
To do that,
you just have to calculate
the multivariate equation
for discriminant analysis
by squaring the delta.
That just kidding.
You literally just pace
in a single line of code.
The real question is how do you know
which of the [inaudible] machine learning
models to use?
Well,
we're trying to classify
an image as either an iris
flour or not an Irish flour,
so we know that this is
a classification problem,
therefore we'll need to use a classify
or okay, that narrows our options,
but what type?
Like there are a lot of those to my gut
reaction is to use a deep neural network
because it just sounds dope. You know what
I mean? But there are countless others.
The answer is it depends.
It depends on the size of your data and
your application requirements. Currently,
if you have a lot of data,
deep neural networks pretty
much outperform every other
machine learning model
across a wide variety of use cases. But
in our case, we only have 150 samples.
So use something simple and standard.
A linear classifier will set
the preclass parameter to three.
You can also easily just switch out
the model with another one and see the
difference in accuracy.
It's just one line of code,
like that's all it would take to use a
deep neural net to classify this if we
want it to. That way you'll know which
one works best. Now we picked our model.
It's time to train it.
Training is the actual learning step.
As your model iterates with the Dataset,
it gets better and better at prediction.
Since we're using a classifier,
we've seen a called the [inaudible]
method on our object to train.
Our model is our training algorithm.
This meant that will input the
training data set into our model,
finding patterns in the
data boom, done. Now,
whenever we input a new flower
farmer testing data set,
it'll automatically be able to classify
it as one of the three types of iris
flour.
We can see internal at the accuracy
score for classification is pretty high.
How easy was that?
Just seven lines of code and now you have
your first model trained and ready to
recognize flowers.
You just made a learning machine and
you can use the same model to classify
other things like cars and
dresses and Republican candidates.
Machine learning can be applied to so
many different things from fraud detection
to generating paintings like the Casa.
If you'd like to see more machine
learning videos, please subscribe.
I'm going to release a lot of them,
and for now I've got to go fix a
runtime error, so thanks for watching.